hey books to embarrass here author of
the 4-hour workweek tools Titans etc you
might imagine that all my days are good
days I wake up and I conquer anxiety and
doubt lack of clarity with a mental
karate-chop and I just annihilate the
day hitting homeruns every single pitch
that's thrown my way
that's not really how it works usually I
wake up a little groggy
maybe I got bad sleep had too much wine
who knows and stumble through my day
occasionally I have a good day and that
is quite frankly enough for me and let
me explain some of the questions I ask
some of the coping mechanisms I use when
the day gets off on the wrong foot for
whatever reason maybe I find myself at
lunch or after lunch feeling like I
haven't accomplished anything what do I
do in such cases well the first is
really a question that I use many many
many many times throughout a given se
week a month and that is which of these
from looking at my to-do list much of
which is probably undone in a case like
this which one of these if accomplished
would make everything else easier or
irrelevant I'll say it again which one
of these if checked off would make
everything else easier or irrelevant you
name less important or completely
unimportant and the other question that
you can use which is more or less the
same is which of these if checked off
would leave me satisfied with my day
which one of these third question and
eventually you will come up with an
answer that is actionable is which of
these if done creates more time for me
next week and it could be next month it
could be tomorrow but next week I find
to be useful as a timeline and this will
generally point to some type of process
or system that you can improve so okay
maybe you're not going to hit a certain
milestone or ship a certain article or
something as a finished work product but
you can improve a system or a process
they'll actually probably have a higher
ROI over time and effect many many other
individual projects okay a which one of
these if accomplished would
make everything else easier or element
number two which one of these would we
be satisfied with my entire day if it
was the only thing I accomplished on
this list today and then last which one
of these will create more time for me
next week or more time for other people
for that matter and then I would also
say that you don't have to be super
super productive every day and maybe if
you're in some type of zero-sum game
you've chosen to be a venture back
startup where everyone arsons everyone
that you have three or four nearly
identical companies all clawing for
market share and it's some type of
network effect based business who knows
in such a case okay maybe you've signed
up for the full contact sport that is
the venture-backed startup world too bad
you have 80 hour weeks from here until
it either succeeds or it blows to pieces
in a supernova of capital destruction
aside from that if you are say a writer
a an entrepreneur even CEO I know plenty
of CEOs certainly fall in this category
you're not going to be super productive
and on point every day and that's okay
so it's not as though you have to have a
minimum number of hours each day within
which you're hyper productive in fact I
know a lot of people who will go through
periods of being very very unproductive
for say II a handful of days maybe a
handful of weeks if they're on a
deadline and just stuck in a rut because
it relates to say music writing or
anything else you don't have to get a
lot of things right if you pick the
right things so this comes back and I'm
not going to be label the point read the
effective executive by Peter Drucker
what you do matters a lot more than how
much you do or how well you do things if
you pick the right targets you can get a
very very high ROI because you have an
Archimedes lever what does that mean
Archimedes lever means in this
particular context you're choosing
saying projects and goals that have
beneficial side effects even if they
don't turn out as planned so you're
choosing say and this is very much
borrowed from Scott Adams who created
Dilbert which projects and so on can I
commit myself to through which I will
develop skills and relationships that
persist even if
they fail from the outside world and so
if I do a podcast and I commit six
episodes even if that podcast goes
nowhere it's how I thought about it
which skills and relationships can I
develop in the process of doing six
episodes that will make the exercise
worth it
all right and it will transcend that
that's also one of the tricks and if you
find yourself saying by mid-afternoon
and feeling really unproductive you've
done nothing productive for the day you
can't quite figure out how to work your
way out of it but I've found myself
doing as perhaps just a self-imposed
therapy is saying okay maybe today is an
achievement day today it's just going to
be gratitude and appreciation day so let
me go for a walk
let me notice the small things let me do
a nice thing for someone in line and buy
coffee for the person behind me at
Starbucks whatever it might be and focus
on the other side of the coin which i
think is equally important for
contentment in any form of well-being or
happiness than that is appreciating what
you have so if you can't get what you
want you can practice wanting what you
have and as fortune-cookie as that may
sound I think that if you can't be happy
as what you have you will never get
anything that will make you happy so you
have to practice both achievements and
if your flubbing that for the day or
just like with with okay airball you're
just not making it happen okay maybe
that is a sign from the universe or
whatever power you want to choose that
you can take the day and focus on
gratitude because that has a much less
of a stress associated with it in terms
of pass/fail that is something you can
always make the most of even if you only
have a few hours left in the day so
those are a few of the things that I do
when the day gets off on the wrong foot
or I feel like I am getting absolutely
[ __ ] all done with my day so hopefully
that helps good luck
thanks for watching the video I have
more tips and tactics and actionable
stuff to share every week I send out an
exclusive newsletter called five bullet
Friday it's totally free takes about
five minutes to read it includes what
I'm reading what type of tips I've
received from world-class experts weird
gadgets and gizmos that I found from say
Japan or God knows where all sorts of
really really esoteric but valuable
stuff that you probably wouldn't find
yourself so check it out five bullet
Friday right here